ray Ratto NBC Sports Bay Area insider at
a column today talking about the Oakland
Raiders and I know it's only one game
ray but boy we love to overreact what
are the locals thinking about their
Oakland Raiders call they're
overreacting yeah I mean well first of
all it's federal law you're supposed to
secondly it's the only reason people pay
attention to anything anyway
yeah I need to know what to think after
three minutes of information I mean that
that's just that is the culture now
we're in a hurry so no I well it's it's
a little different with the Raiders
though in fairness because the fans are
operating on a timeline that Jon Gruden
isn't Jon Gruden when he took the job
said he wanted to bring a championship
to Oakland which meant within the next
two years because they're moving to Las
Vegas
well everything he's done since then has
indicated pretty loudly that he intends
to tear down what the Raiders had you
know for good or ill and aim toward 2020
or 2022 mil be fully in place so I think
that there's a there's a clear
disconnect between what he wants to do
as the practical cynical football guy
and what the fans thought he wanted to
do when they fell in love with him the
day he got hired so that's it's not so
much an overreaction it's almost like a
weird sort of you know broken heart sort
of thing I mean I I don't think they had
any illusions that this was going to be
a phenomenal year but when they traded
khalil Mac all of a sudden it suddenly
hit everybody oh my god we're gonna go
five and 11 again we always go 5 and 11
he was supposed to be the guy who ended
five and 11 and here we are again so I
think it's more that than it is
overreaction but yes they would like to
strangle him today that's what you're
getting at yeah and I said this
yesterday that I didn't think the
Raiders were gonna do anything the next
two years that you have the old
roster in the NFL you traded away Khalil
Mack because you don't want to there's
no reason to spend that money on that
guy and having played for you over the
next couple of years because you're not
going to be ready to go and when you get
to Las Vegas
I guess my big question is when you get
to Vegas is Derek Carr still your
quarterback ray
well that suddenly become an open
question because he looked
comprehensively awful Monday night you
know and you know there were excuses for
a couple of three interceptions and they
were playing a clearly superior team in
the Rams which is probably the one part
of the overreaction that that is truly
overreaction it's unlikely that Derek
Carr is going to see a defense as good
as that one the rest of the way but you
know again with with Raider fans this is
about we have two years to get something
out of this because the 25 years that
the Raiders have been in Oakland since
they came back in in 1995 have been
mostly awful and they'd like to get a
little bit for their investment before
they go watch it go to Nevada so I mean
that's what's tin geing a lot of this
for Raider fans at least in California
which is we don't have a lot of time
with these guys left and we don't want
to see what we've seen for most of the
last two decades Jon Gruden was a little
sensitive I think with the interview
with Lisa Salters prior to the game on
Monday night where he was giving his
opinion that Khalil Mack never wanted to
be there
I guess my thought was well does that
mean Aaron Donald did not want to be
with the Rams because they were sort of
doing the same thing it's just the Rams
are ready to win now the Raiders are not
there for Aaron Donald we're going to
pay you because we may win a Super Bowl
and we're not paying Khalil Mack because
we're not going to be a playoff team
what did you make them Heidi I think
there's a lot of that I think he was
this really offended by the fact that
Khalil Mack didn't come racing into his
arms the day of the press conference so
I mean I think there's some of that I
think there's some of that old school
well if you're not here when I want you
here it means you don't want to be here
at all
that sort of way that coaches have of
positioning players who don't leap high
when they bark so I think there was some
of that too but anybody who believes
what a coach says at any given moment on
any given subject simply hasn't been
paying attention for the last 40 years I
mean just if you're going to if you're
going to listen to coach is expecting
wisdom just just save the effort and sit
home and drink
you're better off he's ray Ratto NBC
Sports Bay Area insider
turn our attention to the 49ers because
there were great expectations lofty
expectations and all of a sudden you'll
face a very good Minnesota team so we're
our Niner fans today they're a little
they're a little less delusional about
the overreaction stuff because I think
everybody knew that Minnesota was
clearly better and they're playing in
Minnesota and I don't think if they gave
a moment of rational thought to it that
they thought that Jimmy Garoppolo would
never lose a game so I think in that way
it'd be had they were disappointed
because he didn't look very good and
they saw some of the flaws that this
team still has because it's already in
its rebuild mode but I think if they
don't look good this week then you'll
start getting the overreaction a 49er
fans are a little late on that but I
think they can rally and overreact at
the best or if you give them one more
bad performance yeah I just thought that
just because and Jimmy Garoppolo numbers
during that five-game winning streak to
close out last season they weren't great
numbers I mean they were Kaepernick
esque and all of a sudden we're gonna
crown him with a big contract and
expectation level of eight nine wins
this year
what do you think is realistic for them
realistic I think for them is seven and
nine or eight Nate but remember Jimmy
Garoppolo has got to clear the high bar
that was set by Blaine Gabbert
a year ago so you know anything that was
better than that with this team was
going to look phenomenal
you know it the weird thing about 49er
fans is the
think that every quarterback who's in
their employ is Joe Montana and Steve
Young well you know they couldn't figure
out how to enjoy Alex Smith you know
they they loved Colin Kaepernick with
all their internal organs until all of a
sudden he was on a bad team then they
hated him and now it's a whole different
argument on a whole different level
so when Garoppolo came in they said well
we know he's better than Blaine Gabbert
and we think we swindled Bill Belichick
so all of a sudden you know Garoppolo is
that guy he's you know he's the future
because he's way better than we had and
we basically you know stole the Patriots
wallet to get him
so I think he came in with with
expectations that were higher than they
ought to be I mean he may still turn out
to be pretty good but without a running
back which is key to remember here
because jerk mccannon got hurt without a
running back they're going to be
one-dimensional and they don't have the
kind of wide receivers to get away with
it so I think they're gonna struggle
some I mean they're not they're not a
playoff team to my mind but then again I
thought the Raiders would go fifteen and
one without Khalil Mac your snark your
snark is alive and well early in the
morning here ray we appreciate that I
poured a cup of coffee in my eye and I
was ready to go for you always great to
talk to you right thank you
you still have the Golden State Warriors
yeah I think we'll get by with them for
a couple more years but the
deterioration you can already see is
coming yeah you're honest you're AB Co
is gonna be a real problem yeah I can
tell thank you Ray that's a roundel NBC
Sports Bay Area insider for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you
[Music]
he's